MODERN DAY BURGLARS TOOLKIT TO
THE CONCERNS ABOUT TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS SITTING IN A
VULNERABLE PLACE AT THE
FACILITY.
NEW CONCERNS TONIGHT THAT DONALD
TRUMP'S FLORIDA RESORT,
MAR-A-LAGO DID NOT MEET THE
STANDARDS NEEDED TO STORE TOP
SECRET CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
>> YOU HAVE THIS PERFECT STORM
OF INTELLIGENCE, INTEREST AND
POOR SECURITY.
ALL IN ONE PLACE IN FLORIDA.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO A
REVIEW BY CNN'S KEVIN LIP TACK,
SECURITY HAS COME INTO QUESTION
ON SEVERAL OCCASIONS IN RECENT
YEARS.
ONE NIGHT IN 2017 AT THE RESORT
WHEN TRUMP AND THEN JAPANESE
LEADER SHINZO ABE CONSULTING ON
A NATIONAL SECURITY ISSUE, CLUB
GUESTS WERE CLOSE ENOUGH TO TAKE
PHOTOS LIKE THESE.
IN VIEW OF THE GUESTS ON THE
PATIO, DOCUMENTS WERE
ILLUMINATED BY THE LIGHT OF A
CELL PHONE.
>> THE FACT THAT HE HAS THESE
DOCUMENTS LYING AROUND AND
SHARES IT WITH A FOREIGN
NATIONAL THAT IS A PRIME
MINISTER AND WHO KNOWS WHO ELSE
IS INCREDIBLY SERIOUS AND IT
SHOWS A GENERAL LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY SYSTEM WORKS.
>> Reporter: ANOTHER POST FROM A
MAR-A-LAGO GUEST SHOWED THE
GUEST STANDING WITH AN AIDE WHO
HE SAID HELD THE PRESIDENT'S
NUCLEAR LAUNCH CODES SATCHEL. IT
WAS UNCLEAR HOW CLOSE THE GUEST
GOT TO THE SATCHEL.
IN 2019, A CHINESE BUSINESS
WOMAN WAS ARRESTED FOR
TRESPASSING AT MAR-A-LAGO.
>> SHE CARRIED INTO MAR-A-LAGO A
MODERN DAY BURGLARS TOOLKIT.
>> INCLUDING A THUMB DRIVE, A
LAPTOP AND EXTERNAL HARD DRIVE
AND FOUR CELL PHONES.
PROSECUTORS SAID THEY LATER
FOUND IN HER HOTEL ROOM A DEVICE
TO DETECT HIDDEN CAMERAS AND
THOUSANDS OF DOLLAR IN CASH.
ONE INTELLIGENCE VETERAN WORRIES
ABOUT WHO ELSE COULD HAVE
BREACHED THE COMPOUND AT ANY
POINT.
>> IF I WERE A HOSTILE
INTELLIGENCE SERVICE, I WOULD
HAVE TRIED TO RECRUIT A
MAINTENANCE PERSON, A MAID,
MIDDLE MANAGEMENT, A SECRETARY,
ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT COMES AND
GOES WITHIN MAR-A-LAGO ALL OF
THE TIME.
>> Reporter: IN 2018, WHILE THE
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY WERE AT
MAR-A-LAGO, A COLLEGE FRESHMAN
WAS ABLE TO GET ON TO THE
GROUNDS BY WALKING THROUGH A
TUNNEL FROM THE BEACH.
PROSECUTORS SAID HE WAS SCREENED
FOR WEAPONS BY THE SECRET
SERVICE AT SOME POINT.
BUT WASN'T STOPPED FROM ENTERING
THE PROPERTY.
EVEN THOUGH HE WASN'T SUPPOSED
TO BE THERE.
>> IT WAS JUST WAITING FOR
DISASTER.
YOU COULD WALK INTO THE POOL,
THERE IS NOBODY STANDING THERE.
>> Reporter: AUTHOR LAWRENCE
LEMMER HAS WRITTEN A BOOK ON
MAR-A-LAGO AND SAID HE'S BEEN ON
THE ESTATE SEVERAL TIMES.
TRUMP'S PERSONAL ATTITUDE TOWARD
SECURITY IS THERE IS THE
PROBLEM.
>> HE'S COMFORTABLE.
BECAUSE HE HAS TO BE ADORED.
HE CAN'T STAND TO BE ALONE.
HE WANTS TO HAVE PEOPLE AROUND
HIM ALL OF THE TIME CELEBRATING.
SO WHEN HE WALKS INTO
MAR-A-LAGO, PEOPLE STAND UP.
HE NEEDS THAT.
HE'S HUNGRY FOR THAT.
>> Reporter: REGARDING THE
LATEST REPORTING OF SENSITIVE
DOCUMENTS REMAINING AT
MAR-A-LAGO, CNN HAS REPORTED
THAT ONE OF TRUMP'S ATTORNEYS
CLAIMED EARLIER THIS SUMMER THAT
NO CLASSIFIED MATERIAL REMAINED
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
THEY SAID HE USED HIS
PRESIDENTIAL PREROGATIVE BUT
THEY HAVE NOT INFORMED OF A
FORMAL PROCESS TAKING PLACE.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>>> JOINING US NOW, CNN
POLITICAL ANALYST CARL
BERNSTEIN, ONE OF THE JOURNAL
IFL WHO EXPOSED THE WATERGATE
SCANDAL.
OF ALL OF THE LINES THAT RICHARD
NIXON CROSSED, WAS HE EVER
WILLING TO PUT THE COUNTRY'S
NATIONAL SECURITY IN JEOPARDY AS
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS BY
TAKING TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO HIS FLORIDA BEACH
CLUB?
>> NO.
WHAT NIXON DID DO WAS USE
NATIONAL SECURITY POLICY TO HIS
OWN POLITICAL ADVANTAGE.
BUT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY AND AT DONALD TRUMP
AS AN EVENT IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS COUNTRY, UNLIKE ANYTHING
WE'VE SEEN.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, DONALD TRUMP, WHO
WE KNOW DEMONSTRABLY IS A
SEDITIONIST PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW OF HIS CRIMINALITY
BEYOND DOUBT.
WE KNOW OF HIS INSTABILITY AND
ALL OF THOSE THINGS ARE KNOWN
PARTICULARLY BY MEMBERS OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ON CAPITOL HILL
WHO HAVE BEEN SO CRAVEN THAT
THEY HAVEN'T SPOKEN OUT ABOUT
WHAT THEY KNOW.
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
LOOK AT AND COULD TALK ABOUT
PERHAPS A LITTLE BIT NOW.
>> THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
IN THE WAKE OF THE FBI SEARCH OF
MAR-A-LAGO, CARL, TRUMP AND HIS
ALLIES HAVE FUELED ANGER AND
DISTRUST TOWARD SOME OF OUR
NATION'S BEDROCK INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDING THE FBI AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, FORWARD
COURTS FOR THAT MATTER AS WELL.
DID YOU EVER THINK YOU WOULD SEE
A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SHOW SUCH REGARD FOR
THESE KEY AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS.
>> NO.
ALMOST EVERYTHING THAT DONALD
TRUMP DID AS PRESIDENT AND AS AN
EX-PRESIDENT IS UNLIKE ANYTHING
WE'VE SEEN.
WE HAVE DONALD TRUMP AND A FAR
RIGHT REPUBLICAN PARTY WHICH IS
ENTHRALLED TO HIS
AUTHORITARIANISM AND EXCESSES
AND WHY DONALD TRUMP IN PART HAS
MANAGED TO PRODUCE IN TERMS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE GOALS, THE
JUDICIAL GOALS OF THE FAR RIGHT,
OF MITCH McCONNELL AND THE
JUDICIARY, OF AUTHORITARIANISM
AND TO THE POINT OF REALLY
MOVING TOWARD THE ACCEPTANCE OF
HATRED IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE HATRED OF SOME RELIGIOUS
GROUPS, THE HATRED OF SOME
ETHNICITIES.
NOT TO SAY THAT IT IS THE POLICY
OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, BUT
RATHER THAT THE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAVE NOT MADE IT THEIR
BUSINESS TO SAY THIS IS NOT OUR
AGENDA.
DONALD TRUMP'S AUTHORITARIANISM,
THAT IS NOT OUR AGENDA.
WE HAVEN'T HAD THAT.
AND I THINK ONE OF THINGS
THATTED HAS TO DO WITH
JOURNALISM, WITH OUR REPORTING.
I DON'T KNOW OF MANY REPORTS ON
CAPITOL HILL, MANY NATIONAL
REPORTERS UNDERSTAND FROM THEIR
SOURCES WHO ARE ASSISTANTS AND
STAFF OF MOST OF THE LEADERS OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ON THE HILL
IN THE SENATE, A GREAT NUMBER OF
HOUSE MEMBERS, THEY ARE BEING
TOLD HOW THEIR BOSSES ARE IN
PRIVATE DESPISE DONALD TRUMP,
HOLD HIM IN UTTER CONTEMPT,
THINK HE IS A CRIMINAL, THINK HE
IS DANGEROUS.
THAT IS WHAT MANY MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE SAY, THEIR AIDES SAY TO
ME AND OTHERS.
SAME IN THE HOUSE.
AND YET WE ALLOW THE STORIES TO
GO ON THAT AS IF THERE IS GREAT
BELIEF IN THIS PRESIDENT AMONG
THESE SAME REPUBLICAN LEADERS
AND MEMBERS OF THE CONGRESS.
WE NEED -- I DID A STORY BACK
OH, A YEAR OR TWO AGO, TWO YEARS
AGO, SAYING THAT 21 MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE, ACCORDING TO THEIR
AIDES, DESPISED DONALD TRUMP,
HOLD HIM IN CONTEMPT AND I NAMED
THEM.
AND THERE WAS MAYBE ONE OR TWO
DENIALS FROM THOSE SENATORS.
I GOT A CALL THE NEXT DAY FROM A
REPUBLICAN SENATOR.
HE SAID, CARL, THE NUMBER IS
REALLY CLOSEST TO 40.
THIS IS THE WAY DONALD TRUMP --
THESE REPUBLICANS IN THE
LEADERSHIP KNOW WHO HE IS.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE DANGER TO
THE COUNTRY POSED BY HIM.
AND YET THEY ARE SO CRAVEN, TO
AFRAID OF BEING UNELECTED, SO
AFRAID OF BEING PRIMARIED THAT
THEY WILL NOT DO WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS DURING THE RICHARD
NIXON CONSPIRACY DID, GET UP AND
SAY, WE CANNOT HAVE CRIMINALITY
IN OUR PRESIDENT, FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HE MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AND INDEED WE ARE
NOW SEEING A PRESIDENT, A FORMER
PRESIDENT